نرصد الوضع الانساني الوضع الصحي في ظل
ارتفاع اعداد المصابين من المدنيين
والقتلى وايضا الوضع في المستشفيات
والقدرات
حدود قدرات المؤسسات الصحيه لمواجهات هذا
التحدي الانسان نرصده مع الدكتوره عبير
زكريا من الخرطوم وهي عضو اللجنه
التمهيديه لنقابه اطباء السودان مرحبا بك
دكتور عبير زكريا حدثينا عن حصلكم الان
لاعداد القتلى والجرحى لحد الان الذي
تمكنتم من من يعني ربما حصرهم وبشكل مؤكد
السلام والرحمه والبركات اولا عبرتكم كل
الشعب الثاني في فقده الجلل
واتمنى الشفاء للمصابين والجرحى وعوده
المنقودين
دعني اوضح اولا التمهيديه لنقابه اطباء
السودان هذه الحرب حرب المدن التي ما زالت
مستمره رغم الهدنه الرابعه ودخلت
على الثالث اي التزام من طرفايه القتال
وما زالت الاشتباكات مستمره ومتصاعده في
مدن وولايات من
اكثرت عنه مجملًا منذ بدايه هذه
الاشتباكات حتى الان ما يقارب 295 قتيل
مدني و1,790 حاله وفاه بين المدنيين ايضا
وما زالت الاجتماع والوضع
ين حاله وفاه ما يقارب 295 ووضع وضع هذه
الحالات التقريبيه لان هنالك صعوبه في
التنقل
لحفر بدقه تامه للحالات
عدد الجرحى 1790
طيب ماذا عن المستشفيات وطبعا عدد كبير
جدا منها الان اصبح مشهورا وخارج الخدمه
تزداد نسبه خروج المستشفيات من العمل
من اصل اساسيه
هنالك
يعمل بكفاءه اقل بتقديم اسعافات اوليه فقط
من فضلك لو تعيد المعلومه دكتوره عبير
زكريا لم نسمع جيدا عدد المستشفيات التي
اصبحت خارج الخدمه صوت متقطع جدا يعني
مشكله في الصوت
شكلي كان يقدمات اوليه فقط
وانقطاع التيار الكهربائي المستمر انقطاع
الماء مستمر القطاع الاكسجين مستمر وهنالك
صعوبه في التنقل ولا يوجد اي ممرات
ومسارات امنه
ماذا عن الدعم الجنسي الجانب اللوجيسي
عفوا الادويه وغير ذلك
ايضا توجد صعوبات كبيره جدا لان هنالك
غياب تام لصوت الحكمه وانعدام للحاله
الانسانيه وعدم التراث لطرفي القتال
من عظم وصولا التي تصعب
الطبيه لتقديم خدمات طبيه
للوصول الى المرافق الصحيه فهنالك
كبيره جدا الكوادر الطبيه الاخصائي
للجراحه والتخدير والاطباء العموميين
وتقنيه تمريض وكل الكوادر الطبيه
اشكرك دكتوره عبير زكريا عضو لجسم تمهيديه
لنقابه اطباء السودان من الخرطوم شكرا لك
دكتوراه